dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly affair it's been
quite awhile since we've talked about a
paper on fluid simulations since my
withdrawal symptoms are already kicking
in today I simply have to talk to you
about this amazing pain simulator
program that runs in real-time and on
our mobile devices these handheld
devices typically have a lower image
resolution compared to desktop computers
therefore it is indeed a challenge to
put together a solution that artists can
use to create detailed paintings with
and to accomplish this this piece of
work offers several killer features for
instance the paint pigment concentration
can be adjusted the direction of the
brushstrokes is also controllable and
third this technique is powered by a
viscoelastic shallow-water simulator
that also supports simulating multiple
layers of paint this is particularly
challenging as the inner paint layers
may have already dried when adding a new
wet layer on top of them this all has to
be simulated in a way that is physically
plausible but we are not done yet with
many different kinds of paint types that
we are using the overall outlook of our
paintings are dramatically different
depending on the lighting conditions
around them to take this effect into
consideration this technique also has an
intuitive feature where the effect of
virtual light sources is also simulated
and the output is changed interactively
as we tilt the tablet around and get
this gravity is also simulated and the
paint trickles down depending on the
orientation of our tablet according to
the laws of physics really cool the
paper also shows visual comparisons
against similar algorithms and clearly
artists who work with these substances
all day know exactly how they should
behave in reality so the ultimate
challenge is always to give it to them
and ask them whether they have enjoyed
the workflow and found the simulation
faithful to reality let the artists be
the judge the user study presented in
the paper revealed that the artists
loved the user experience and they
expressed that it's second to none or
testing ideas I am sure that with a few
improvements this could be the ultimate
tool for artists
to unleash their creative potential
while sitting outside and getting
inspired by nature thanks for watching
and for your generous support now see
you next time
[Music]